[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's a Prof hi Martin hi
Walter so we are here people have been
waiting a long time for this one well we
didn't want to do it before we knew what
the man was going to say right correct
so let's jump into it and try and put
the puzzle together that it can make
sense but before we do that Martin we
better pray yes let's open with a word
of
prayer Our Father in Heaven thank you
once again for giving us the opportunity
to do these discussions important um
matters that happen in the world and we
have to put it into prophetic picture so
please help to Enlighten our minds and
guide us through this this discussion in
Jesus name amen
amen now Martin lud
doesn't stand by itself it's not a
standalone uh document no it's actually
an exhortation it's an exhortation I
must say when I read it I was somewhat
disappointed it sounded more like a high
school project than it did well that's
interesting you say that because I think
a lot of people there's always a big
hype like we said before one of these
things come
out why
why is there big but we must we must
realize as I said it's not a stand alone
it has a long
precursor and there are many
suborganizations that have climbed onto
the bandwagon and not only
suborganizations whole political systems
have been raised up whole political
parties have been raised up over years
the whole green movement everything that
goes along with it and uh all the
strikes that you have and the climate
activists and all of this this is a very
very busy program yeah and these are
just little pointers pointing in a
particular direction MH MH and they're
not going to be repeats of what has
already been done and that's I think
where some people miss it they expect in
every single one to have a
clearcut here's the legislation we've
been waiting for and they think it's
going to emanate from the first Beast no
no no the second beast listens to what
mother has to
say and then implements mother's wishes
but mother is not going to implement the
Wishes the second beast has to implement
the wishes and if the second beast looks
like it doesn't want to do what it has
to do or seems to not play ball like a
naughty little child or daughter she
will have to be
reprimanded and brought back into line
yes but we have to look further we have
to look at other issues and other
documents and see what have they put in
place yeah so that when the prophetic
picture is full everything can be
implemented that's true so we have to
look at a little bit of the backdrop so
L
dim uh versus project
2025 let's have a look at a little bit
of world news of late the New York Times
Nationwide alert reaches cell phones TVs
and
radios and they made quite sure in the
United States that they gave it a low
profile in other words they didn't say
why they did it it was just to test the
old equipment to see whether it would
still do the job right yeah
every television radio and cell phone in
the United States broadcast a message on
Wednesday that said this is a test of
the national wireless emergency alert
system and then we don't have to read it
all how often are the tests run on a
national scale this was the seventh time
that a nationwide test of the emergency
alert system has been beamed to radios
and televisions and the was only the
second test transmitted to all cellular
devices so how important is it Martin
that the whole nation becomes integrated
into the web every this is the whole
nation but they also want that's why
digital I IDs and all of that they want
actually the whole world to be in into
this it's just the lead that's it but
the it it applies to everyone does it
apply to to Africa oh for sure sure
every single country so what types of
alerts can I expect well there are very
few circumstances where you will notify
the entire country about something Mr
Schlegel mil said presidential alerts
may be sent in a National
Emergency they didn't Define the
National Emergency exactly have there
ever been false alarms yes January 2018
people in Hawaii received the false
emergency Al warning them of an incoming
ballistic missile I remember that one do
you remember that not much no so this is
the only little clue that it might have
something to do with nuclear events but
otherwise it could be earthquakes
climate disaster what about a
National Climate emergency yes what
about a climate
emergency so this is what happened in
the United States and very interesting
on the exact same day the exact thing
happened in Russia so what happened in
Moscow Sirens wailed across Russia and
TV stations interrupted regular
programming to broadcast warnings
Wednesday as part of a sweeping drills
intended to test the Readiness of the
country's emergency responders amid the
fighting in Ukraine I just wanted to say
yeah they put that part amid the
fighting in Ukraine I think it's just
they they trying to use the Ukraine but
that is not the actual reason why they
not so as part of the drills TV stations
broadcast the notice saying attention
everyone the Readiness of the public
warning system is being tested please
remain calm Russian media said the
exercises scenario mentions the
increasing danger of a conflict between
nuclear Powers so they were a little bit
more blatant about it right now what
whether this actually transpires or not
is it PL planting the seeds of fear it's
the whole time running on that fear
monster not only that is it preparing
the mind for coming calamities yes I
mean climate is the whole time a
fear-mongering I'm also Al always
interested in the way that they they
portray the events and how the media
presents them you know in the old days
it they would say storm name so and so
is approaching baton down the hatches
make sure this that and the other now it
says Mega storm Burling
towards so the words apocalyptic storm
or you know they always use the the
worst storm in human history correct and
then when you when it finally is over
and even if it is very bad mhm it's not
not worse than those that have preceded
it but uh there's a lot about that in
any case the we trying to say is there's
this constant portraying of fear that
the subconscious is constantly waiting
for something something bad to happen
does the Bible say calamities will
increase yes so is the devil preparing
the mind for it and then giving it a
naturalistic or a nuclear Holocaust
flavor whereas it might just be signs of
the times definitely because the Bible
says we should not fear yes and so the
Bible ahead of time warned us these
things will happen but now the devil and
his conies are trying to make you
fearful and always alert of something
bad that will happen where your trust
which is supposed to be directed
somewhere else yeah so Russian media
said the exercises scenario mentions the
The increased danger of a conflict
between nuclear powers and simulates a
response to a situation in which 70% of
Housing and all vital infrastructure
have been destroyed wide areas
contaminated by radioactive fallout and
a general mobilization announced so
coincidentally do you believe that
Martin I don't think there's a lot of
coincidence the US federal government on
Wednesday is testing the emergenc alert
system designed to allow the president
to speak to the American people within
10 minutes during a National Emergency
via Outlets such as radio and television
so Martin the world is being prepared
for something and with all this hype of
crying wolf climate emergency is coming
catastrophe is coming oceans are going
to rise there will be flooding there
will be destruction on a scale that
nobody has ever seen before for this is
Preparatory to something that must
happen in the mind right correct what is
it they want to happen in the mind this
is what we have to look at so this is
all tools tools yes now the climate
emergency is very bad how are nations
going to
react well Sky news report that drivers
in Singapore now need to pay £88,000
for permission to own a car vehicle not
included uh that will put it out of the
reach of how many probably the most all
of them basically unless the
multi-millionaires jump in and buy
everyone a car right so the city state
is the most expensive place in the world
to be a motorist with skyrocketing
prices putting cars out of the reach for
most middle class
singaporeans there's a need to to lower
one's aspirations from achieving the
good life to settling with a good enough
life says sociologist
tan so now we have a few
people not least of which is the pope
himself telling you what is good enough
for you he's going to
decide and all his cronies are going to
say yes and even if they're not his
cronies they have been influenced by his
mindset well it says the mark of a beast
will Taken be taken either on the arm or
the forehead okay now Martin when the
Bible says the whole world wondered in
other words received the same thinking
pattern as the
Beast then this is a very serious issue
very serious well that language also
sounds like CLA Schwab will you will be
yes owning nothing and be happy they're
singing the same tune and they're using
the same instruments now here's another
article Switzerland considers jailing
anyone who Heats rooms above 19°
Centigrade for up to 3 years if the
country is forced to ration gas due to
the Ukraine war all right so the the
legislation is becoming pretty
Draconian it's forerunners for runners
yes forerunners of what because you can
see it's slowly creeping to where this
will head won't there be a time of
trouble such as never was so this this
does this sound like
trouble yes now we live in a town called
hoods sprit right and it's a it's a warm
place too warm for many people so you
get accustomed to to the heat if our
temperature drops below 25° Centigrade
then we grab for blankets yeah and
everybody else thinks it's hot that's
true if you're walking around in London
they say lovely day when it's 11°
Centigrade exactly 25 is a heat wave yes
where people end up in hospital so this
is this is hype so the Department of
Finance explained that the rate for
fines on a daily basis could start at 30
Swiss Franks it's about 26 pounds he
added that the maximum fine could go up
to 3,000 Swiss Franks you know Martin
this kind of legislation they've also
introduced in many countries where it
was illegal to quote certain Bible
verses and you could end up paying fines
towards more or less in this even jail
time even jail time yes so your freedom
of movement your freedom of activity
your freedom of
speech goodbye they're all going out of
the window and it's all for the common
good it's all for brotherly love like
we've we've seen so many times all of
this is for the benefit of humanity yes
it's for the common good for the common
good there's another article from the
National Review from Net Zero to
jail as is obvious by now Net Zero is by
definition
coercive but Net Zero means you have to
stop breathing
yeah because you produce CO2 so if
you're going to produce zero CO2 you
have to stop breathing but I've got news
for you even if you've stopped breathing
you're going to Decay and produce carbon
dioxide so you have to Decay away to
dust before you become net zero this is
ludicrous idiocy excuse me and in any
case if Net Zero becomes the norm in the
atmosphere everything dies because the
plants won't have any nutrients left
left and they won't have anything to
breathe no no and they won't be able to
produce oxygen so the Net Zero world is
one of prohibitions bans and
restrictions as it evolves you will not
be able to buy the type of car that you
might want or cook with the type of
stove you might prefer or even eat more
than a sliver of the beef that you once
enjoyed because a cow produces GRE
housee gases when it dares to breathe or
burp it's like it's worse than a car now
that's interesting when you look at the
news and you see the climate activists
blocking the roads you see the drivers
becoming angry climbing out of their
cars beating up the climate activists
dragging them from the road and carrying
on
driving these people will have to learn
a lesson Mar oh for sure how about uh
a hefty fine Hefty fine or a little bit
of jail time just to get them back in
line what about deprogramming
camps didn't Hillary Clinton just
recently say that all Trump followers
have to be
reprogrammed of course and uh so it
seems the world is being programmed and
anybody who doesn't want to be
programmed is an enemy of the state so
ministers want to Grant themselves
powers to create new criminal offenses
and increase civil penalties as part of
efforts to hit Net Zero
targets under the proposals people who
fall foul of regulations to reduce their
energy consumption could face up to a
year in
prison and fines of up to 15,000 Martin
we're moving up yeah but this is in
Britain yes now
3,000 5,000 50
15,000 M where are the people going to
get this kind of money no jail go so but
then they'll have to let loose some
criminals to let enough space they
remember with a CO situation in South
Africa they had to let loose criminals
to make space for the people that were
violating Co lockdowns exactly so people
who wanted to
breathe had to go to jail and people
that were murderers had to be released
from jail it's all very
logical okay does this create a hype oh
yes now did this kind of talk and this
kind of legislation come about because
of laum or was it there before this is
before Lum that's why we are showing
these things okay so there has been a
movement behind the scenes to reprogram
humanity and if Humanity doesn't learn
then a calamity or two is very useful
mhm now I'm not saying that they
deliberately created the
Calamity but I'm not denying it either
be that as it may whether the Calamity
is natural and produced by other forces
including
demonic or whether it is man-made the
result will be the same we've always
kept to that all right so people could
also be prosecuted for provision of
false
information about Energy Efficiency or
the obstruction of an enforcement
Authority so fake news will be
legislated against but that will be fake
news according to them according to them
yes so 32,000 scientists can say there
is no climate change they all be and one
Pope with zero education in climate
mology says there is and the world has
to be programmed to wonder to think like
the Beast exactly that's how it works
that's how it and it's on its way all
right here's another one a utility
company locked thousands of customers
out of their smart thermostats in
Colorado so thousands of Colorado
residents found themselves locked out of
their smart thermostats during
sweltering temperatures last week in an
effort to prevent power demand from
overwhelming the
grid these people have no idea what it's
like to live in South Africa no no they
think if 5,000 people are without
electricity it's a major disaster we
have continuous rollouts daily and 65
million people sit without power every
for 3 hours four hours per day and
sometimes very much more than that very
very much more so Martin this is uh is
this control yes so it's interesting
that even your solar
systems even if you put in your own
solar system it's coupled to the
web and sometimes something goes wrong
with it but you do not have to get an
agent in to come and fix it they fix it
via the web MH and they can change all
your settings via the web can't they
switch it off via the web switch it off
as well H yeah so in whose control are
you in their's well I don't know if they
implemented but they were talking about
in our country that if you are using
solar power you'll be having to pay a
subsidy or a levy towards the
electricity that you were supposed to
use from the the country's grid which
doesn't work yeah okay so that's the way
it is but not only electricity water as
well if you have a well yeah then they
want to put a meter on it and if you
don't have a well they want to put a
rain meter on your property so that you
can pay Rain Tax I think that's already
implemented if I'm not mistaken so who
owns the environment and who owns the
climate the government can they change
it yes do they use Chemtrails to change
it I think so yes yes okay but be that
as it may if you can control it then you
can use it as a weapon that's a thing
and the weapon can change your mindset
now what if the mindset is associated
with
morality then it becomes interesting
because then it's not just an
environmental issue it becomes a moral
issue right so let's get some morality
into it here is the BC Catholic letters
walking to church on carfree Sunday so
they want to introduce legislation that
will lower the carbon footprint and
walking to church will do that so
walking to church will put less
greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere you better stop breathing
while you're walking as well because uh
that could be problematic particularly
if a whole family is walking to church
right yeah so
Sunday and introducing
legislation regarding Sunday is this a
moral issue yes okay it's part of the
moral law right
here's the Daily Press faith and values
slowing down and finding true Sabbath
rest so Barbara Brown Taylor reminiscing
about her own childhood suggests that
the Commandment might as well have been
remember the Sabbath day and keep it
boring she says Sunday was a day where
you couldn't wear blue jeans play cards
ride bikes or go to the movies all you
could do was go to church in the morning
morning sit at home bored and then go
back to church again later in the
day but she suggests having a you know a
less restrictive day go for a hike have
coffee or wine with a friend waste time
together play an instrument write or
sketch just for fun not to be productive
not to improve yourself instead try to
savor the things that we call life and
remember that it is a gift
so there is this
drive to change the mindset of humanity
back towards a Sunday rest mindset but
it's also to include more people that if
you don't want to go to church at least
go for a hike to have coffee with a
friend just take the day off so the mark
can be on the hand or in the forward you
might be convinced that this is morally
right or just go along with it because
it's a day to
relax another article Portuguese
Catholics fight to bring back the
workfree Sunday the fight for a workfree
Sunday more than fair is necessary so
that there is family life for everyone
so that families all workers can live
together and fraternize and build a
fairer and more solidary world the
organization said so l
came out in
2015 it propagated Sunday legislation
didn't it yeah now here you have all of
these things happening in the background
and now we're going to La yeah so this
is already been achieved so we can see
that organizations and people in their
personal capacity are already pushing
for this Sunday rest we private letters
we have organizations we have churches
we have government organizations all of
them climbing onto the bandwagon has the
Jerusalem Post from September the 24th
our greatest sin is emissions we must
repent for climate change this is an
opinion published in the Jerusalem Post
are these opinions there to sway other
opinions yes okay and it shows you that
it's across the there's nobody that's
excluded out of this and even if it is a
lie if you repeat a lie often enough
people will believe it right on this day
of
awe there is no more notable cause for
the Jewish people than saving Humanity
itself ensuring that God's covenant not
to wipe out the planet with Rising
Waters will be in some small measure
because of our actions so so there's a
new Mission yeah for Israel not to
represent God but to save man Humanity
from climate change that's it okay
climate sin all right it is for this
purpose that we have been created that
we have survived and flourished there is
no higher fulfillment of the Jewish
Mission than to honor and save the
Majesty of God's creation and to do so
as individuals and part of a global
Jewish Collective with Israel as our
national platform because of Shabbat
observance in Israel greenhouse gas
emissions are reduced by a third and are
nearly zero on yon kipur once
again on and a special day yur the day
of atonement Martin we are living in the
anti-typical day of atonement yon kipur
so they want the whole world to realize
what a Wonder wonderful effect it is to
keep
Shabbat because it reduces climate
catastrophes or climate emissions so
Martin the whole world the rest of the
world should take a lesson but which day
would they Implement you've seen in the
previous articles they going for the
false Sabbath all right so they'll be
going for the first day of the week yes
and they want to legislate it so the
battle will take place largely in the
Christian
if every denomination of the Jewish
people truly Sanctified Shabbat as a
non-consumer day of rest and this
example was followed by other Faith
communities then Shabbat would save the
Jewish people along with the entire
planet is that planting an idea oh for
sure has it been absorbed by West
Society yes and if people would want to
say yes but they are talking about the
Saturday Sabbath the Jewish people yeah
we've shown articles previously where
there are climate people in Israel that
is for a Sunday rest correct so let's
get in the big corporations let's see
what uh Apple has to say about it of
course we shouldn't forget and we when
we talk about the company Apple that
there is a bite in the apple and let
people make of that what they want to
Martin do we have to say something to
that well it's interesting I think a lot
of the world is thinking like
this will the Apple devices run on
batteries Martin I don't know neutral BR
is there such a thing don't you have to
do mining to get the components of a
battery don't you have to use equipment
to get it out of the
ground uh don't uh doesn't the
production of car batteries for the new
generation electric cars put more carbon
into the atmosphere than the original
coal system did they don't think so no
they don't think so and and they happily
ignore it right but also the portrayal
of mother Earth we'll see but is this
all maybe linked to what the pope has in
store for this it's for a mindset it's
for a mindset and the goddess is Mother
Earth yeah it's Gaia but let's turn now
to the documents this was just a
backdrop uh I think this is going to be
quite a lengthy discussion by the looks
of things now before Lum came out this
is what the Catholic World Report had to
say on the issue so they wrote The
Following article here is what I hope
lusi 2.0 will say so this is before it
came out what did they want out of this
document the human person according to
Genesis has a privileged place in the
world the pestic tradition spoke of man
as a singer as the one who gives voice
to the the rest of God's creation to
Proclaim his
glory now we spoke about glory in
previous ones it's about the character
the law that portrays the character of
God now let's see what these Roman
Catholic institutions were hoping for
but I also thought that the Catholic
Church needed to be saying something
more than CNN does or at least not just
the same thing with the same Pious words
and a dash of holy water added I also
thought The secular environmental
movement posed some dangers to Christian
Orthodoxy and I believe the pope needed
to point them out what I'm suggesting is
that if we look at the human person
integrally we need to consider the total
environment including the moral
environment in which we live together
Martin do they want Morality In the
document definitely and have did we see
that other people are also speaking
about it the sin of omission correct it
would seem to me that this requires the
kind of holistic seamless approach that
Demands a comprehensive view of what we
are doing and not focus only on some
part of the physical environmental
agenda so they were hoping for a modal
director nor in the name of that
partnership and fraternal dialogue
should the church neglect what is
uniquely her
responsibility the overall human
environment with its physical and moral
Dimensions they want moral legislation
they want moral Direction they don't
just want a CNN documentary on how bad
the climate is no but we can also say
that in the in cyclical la da to see
that was it was already there yeah it
was already there now m when we read
L there was very little moral directive
in it that's true I mean God I think was
mentioned three or four times Jesus once
or twice the whole document was actually
a lot of
scientific jargon jargon with a little
bit of pantheism thrown in here and
there and the rest was a high school
project using Popular Science and not
true science as to the
situation all right and Martin there's a
big fur in the world about this because
now the whole world has to change you
have to go from from uh gas-driven
vehicles to electric vehicles and as we
said the production of electric vehicles
plus the dangers that go along with the
batteries that are exploding that even
ships don't want to transport these cars
anymore because of the fire risks
involved etc
etc but the mindset has to change so the
Auto industry has to change has that
brought about uh strikes yeah many in
the US has had big ones I don't know if
it's even stopped yet all right now if
you're going to stop all of these major
industries aren't the trade unions going
to be up in arms oh for sure all right
now we read in the spirit of Prophecy in
letter 200 of 1903 that the trade unions
will be one of the agencies that will
bring upon this Earth a time of trouble
such as has not been since the world
began yeah you have to come down from
your standard of living you have to
accept what is essential but not
necessarily what you want right exactly
did we see that in the articles that we
were showing yes and people are going to
be unhappy so here's another quote
political corruption is destroying love
of justice and regard for truth and even
in free America rulers and legislators
in order to secure public favor will
yield to the popular demand for a law
enforcing Sunday observance Liberty of
conscience which has cost so great a
sacrifice will no longer be respected in
the soon coming conflict we shall see
exemplified the prophet's word
the dragon was wroth with a woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
the conflict will have to hone in on the
law of God true and all these things
everything that we've just seen we have
to look is this already in L and now L
di is it getting this together and we
must remember that if you want to attack
God's law in it
entirety then you have to attack the
Seal of God which is the authoritative
commandment which gives validity to the
entire law because it explains who the
lawgiver is and what his power is yes so
modern Sunday legislation will be an
attack on the law of God for sure so
let's go to the document itself
La as we've said before
very little on
morality because he doesn't have to put
it there yeah but he also doesn't have
to introduce the legislation no he
should just point a finger in a
direction now in L to see he already
referred to Sunday legislation exactly
so he doesn't have to do it in L he had
the whole morality issue and angle in
thei correct so what is he doing now we
must go back to the prophet
picture we have here in on the screen in
the backdrop two beasts that are
involved in bringing the world to the
point of decision one is already his
hand on the legislation the other one is
reaching for it correct so that's the
symbolism of the picture behind us so
this Beast which happens to be the first
piece of Revelation 13 the
papacy has to point the finger towards
the second beast so the mother has to
tell the daughter this is what I want
you to do she's already done it how far
has the second beast
responded and is it only going to
respond after LA or has it already
started to respond after LA to see yeah
it's already making its movement in
darkness all right did the Pope visit
the United States and speak in its
legislative Halls yes he did and those
dates are very interesting and the
implementation thereof and now we are at
the point of
L let's read some of it it is not
helpful to confuse multilateralism with
the world Authority concentrated in one
person or in an elite with excessive
power when we talk about the possibility
of some form of world Authority
regulated by law we need not necessarily
think of a personal Authority we are
speaking above all of more effective
World
organizations equipped with the power to
provide for the global common good the
elimination of hunger and poverty and
the sure defense of fundamental human
rights so he's touting the same issues
again and he's asking for a world
Authority with clout yeah with teeth all
right uh have they started implementing
that during the pandemic yes and did
they want the World Health Organization
to have total authority over every
nation tribe and people that's it
regarding these issues so there's a
forerunner for a pandemic what about a
climate pandemic yes climate crisis is
he asking for a body with the same
Powers okay and every nation would have
to sign away its authority to be subject
to this so is this a universal issue yes
so when the mark of the beast will be
applied to Every Nation tribe and people
and everybody will be forced then the
mechanism the
organizations have to be in place that's
it are they already in place they're
already in place okay it continues to be
regrettable that Global crises are being
squandered when they could be the
occasions to bring about beneficial
changes doesn't that sound very much
like the world economic Forum it's
exactly the same wording doesn't it
sound like Gates that's it we cannot
squander a good opportunity like this a
good calamity never let a good crisis go
to waste never let it go to waste so
legislation has been introduced all
right so now we have to do what look at
prophecy that's it there are two hands
here there's the first beast and there's
the second beast according to prophecy
who's going to be the driving force it's
going to be the second piece that's it
that's the one implementing everything
doesn't it say that he will force
everyone yes but not him through the
second beast he will the second beast
will force everyone to worship the first
Beast right how do you worship the first
Beast by obeying it right worship God
and give glory to him is the message of
the first Angel here is worship the
first beast and give glory to him yeah
Wonder after him Wonder after him
receive his mindset Martin we have to
guard The Avenues of our mind we have to
start read realizing where we are in the
Stream of time because a lot of us are
asleep and say just looking at all of
this as H just another glitch all right
so we have two very distinct points here
asking for a world body with
clout and then saying we cannot allow a
good catastrophe to go by without
utilizing it to get our
legislation in place which they've
done there's another one in the medium
term globalization favors spontaneous
cultural
interchanges greater Mutual knowledge
and processes of integration of peoples
which end up provoking a multilateralism
from below and not simply one determined
by the elites of power then the papacy
in its
falit work towards this goal that's it
bringing all the religions together and
all of them on the climate bandwagon
that's it and then we also now see in
the spirit of Prophecy quote that it
will be the popular demand that gets the
people to bow to this this is that's why
he says it won't be from only the Elites
in power they want the simple ones also
to be implementing so are they working
behind the scenes already to implement
it all for sure it's not going to come
after La it's already there for this
reason I reiterated that unless citizens
control political power National
Regional and Municipal it will not be
possible to control damage to the
environment so now he is talking to the
man in the street you must be involved
and you must have my mindset or else
we're going to have a Calamity and if
you don't come on board with my mindset
then calamities will make sure that you
do that's it and then they can use
Nationwide or even worldwide emergency
broadcasts yes and legislation and a
governing body like the World Health
Organization is already
doing so everybody has to be on board
from the lowest to the highest all the
world world wanded after the
Beast 65 hence the creatures of this
world no longer appear to us under the
merely natural guise because the Risen
one is mysteriously holding them to
himself and directing them towards
fullness as their end Martin when I see
one
capitalized it is a big red flag for me
because this is occult language that is
a applied to
Lucifer the one the wronged one the very
flowers of the field and the birds which
his human eyes contemplated and admired
are now imbued with his radiant presence
if the universe unfolds in God who fills
it completely there's a mystical meaning
to be found in a leaf in a mountain
trail in a DW trop in a poor person's
face the world sings of an infinite love
how can we fail to care for it Martin
this is pantheism that's Mother Earth
this is Mother Earth this is Gaia
worship this is paganism at its best it
is evil what is written there and do you
see how if you just read it and you
don't know this it sounds so good and it
gives glory to Lucifer because Lucifer
is the one
capitalized 72 if we consider that that
emissions per individual in the United
States are about two times greater than
those of individuals living in China and
about seven times greater than the
average of the poorest countries we can
state that a broad change in the
irresponsible Lifestyles connected with
the Western model would have a
significant long-term impact as a result
along with indispensable political
decisions we would be making progress
along the way to genuine care for one
another now this to me is absolutely
fascinating he doesn't care about the
overall emissions of a nation that
doesn't matter no that doesn't matter he
targets the United States that's it so
what he is inferring mhm is that the
United States must lead the way that's
it that's what he's inferring that is
this is the language that's giving the
second beast now the instruction
and the way in which it is
implemented and done will be read from
the legislations of the second beast but
we must remember that the second beast
introduces the legislation so that the
first Beast receives honor and Glory yes
so people that expected L de to actually
talk about the legislation are totally
misreading the signs of the time that's
it and they're waiting for the wrong
institution to do that yes the second
beast must do it so that's why he's
targeting the second piece the United
States of America and this to me is
prophetic
fulfillment as far as the science is
concerned we don't even have to talk
about it because he's quoting Popular
Science and it's like a high school
project and I'm sure he never ever wrote
it some Jesuit expert wrote it for him
and used the Popular Science and ignored
the real science so we don't even have
to talk about it we're interested in the
prophetic aspects so we have pantheism
we have paganism we have
luciferianism we have all of these in
the document we have as you said very
little of Jesus very little of the true
God but we have the request United
States do my bidding that's it that is
exactly where we are at this stage now
here's a very interesting article from
Catholic news agency Pope Francis
launches seven-year lat C action plan
the latac action platform will focus on
seven sectors families parishes schools
hospitals businesses organizations and
religious orders do you think it's uh
coincidence that he's using the number
seven no and I is he applying deity to
himself yes and his prophetic language
seven years is also prophetic okay the
pub explained that the action plan also
has seven goals the response to the Cry
of the Earth the response to the Cry of
the poor ecological economics adoption
of simple Lifestyles ecological
education ecolog iCal
spirituality and Community involvement
how much of humanity does that entail
all all of it all of it and it's also
like we mentioned in the previous ones
it's got moral issues his morality as as
well now what if I despise his moral
issues you will have to get re-educated
oh I'll have to become re-educated I
therefore renew my appeal let us take
care of our mother earth is this a
religious organization or a pagan
organization
it's Pagan it's Pagan let us overcome
the temptation of selfishness that makes
us predators of resources let us
cultivate respect for the gifts of the
earth and creation let us inaugurate a
lifestyle and a society that is finally
EOS
sustainable Martin if we would respect
God then all of these things would fall
into place automatically he leaves God
right out of it that's it he worships
the creature rather than the Creator
exactly doesn't the Bible speak against
that 100% you know and we must realize
this is not a new document or article
this was the plan the action plan and
when was it implemented in
2020 so Mar if you add seven years to
2020 what year do you get to I don't
think I'm going to do that math just now
I get into trouble but you can't add
seven to 2020 you get into trouble so
that means if you're going to get into
trouble I will get into trouble so we'll
leave it to the listeners to add seven
years to
2020 to find out when this action plan
must be complete yeah okay on a journey
that will last for seven years we will
let ourselves be guided by the seven
aims of
laui which will show us the direction
while we pursue the vision of integral
ecology so Martin he's giving years from
2020 to receive his
mindset and have we seen this
happening we see this we see this right
in the articles that we shown before
lodum even came out slowly but surely
all of these things are being
implemented so but this is
luciferian because God is not in this
equation at all and unfortunately the
whole world at this stage is wondering
and encaptured by this okay there is
hope we can all collaborate each one
with his own culture and experience each
one with her own initiatives and
capacities so that our mother earth may
be restored to her original Beauty and
creation May once again shine according
to God's plan which God definitely not
the god of the Bible what's going to
happen to Mother Earth at the second
coming it's going to be totally wiped
out it's going to go to
abusos so Martin are they going to
achieve their objective no no they're
trying to do the
opposite of what the Bible says will
happen now I'm not against taking care
of the environment let's make that very
clear because I've had that numerous
times I hate
pollution destruction all of this and
chemtrails and adding aluminum to the
ground or aluminium as it is pronounced
in other countries and regions is not
conducive to the good environment and
seeding uh with metals and all kinds of
things is not going to be very good for
the
environment and all the spraying and all
of these things I am for the natural
processes that God introduced that's
true because even the food that we grow
yeah yes we don't use chemicals and
pesticides all of this so that we
propagate God's method organic gardening
like he does in his perfect ecosystems
in that sense we are Greenies yes but
I'm not going to bludgeon my neighbor
over the head but uh if you do it God's
way you will automatically be in harmony
with his
creation because you know when I was in
the world a creature was something that
was a commodity you could do with it
whatever you wanted but once you realize
this is God's creation it becomes
special and uh we Advocate Health from
the ground up so there is a way which is
God's way which gives glory to God and
there is a way which is the devil's way
which gives glory to other forces Pagan
forces and to Lucifer so when we say
when they have a article on stating that
Sabbath rest is good for you and all of
that if it was kept the biblical way we
100% agree with that yes but it's not
that way no it's not that way it's
always the devil's way yeah so let's
take it a step further let's not say too
much about L because it doesn't say too
much no but it's it's giving marching
orders correct so let's
reiterate it gives the standard paradigm
with many adjectives to make it sound
powerful then it highlights pantheism
and the need for all Humanity to come on
board it highlights uh organizations
with clout to implement everything it
wants all the people to be involved from
the ground up and it wants the United
States to take the lead that's a summary
of L correct now if the United States
must take the lead then something must
change right yes and what did that
Catholic article say they wanted
morality yes but morality was already in
laatu mhm so is the United States the
second Beast going to come on board as
far as the morality issue is concerned
we've spoken about the pendulum that's
supposed to swing it's supposed to swing
right so let's look at project
2025 building now for a conservative
Victory through policy personnel and
training it is not enough for
conservatives to win elections if we are
going to rescue the country from the
grip of the radical left we need both a
governing agenda and the right people in
place ready to carry this agenda out on
day one of the next conservative
Administration I find it interesting
that day one is so
capitalized this is the goal of the
2025 presidential transition project the
project will build on four pillars that
will collectively pave the way for an
effective conservative
Administration what do they want Martin
they want legislation and they want
moral legislation that's it they want
morality to be brought back they want
the issues addressed that are going
Haywire in the world the whole
lgbtq plus whatever has to be addressed
the whole new woke agenda has to be
addressed the swamp has to be drained
all the same terminology is coming back
now this document exceeds 900 pages and
it's very comprehensive and it was
written by the Heritage Foundation and
it's not only one person that wrote this
it was hundreds correct and wasn't taka
Carlson part of the Heritage Foundation
in the past yes he's very much involved
even when he the day before they fired
him at Fox he had that speech that we
showed correct so this is a very
important Think Tank and they wouldn't
bring out a document exceeding 900 pages
to show the blueprint for a government
of a conservative nature and the
implement ation thereof from day one
yeah do they have a time frame then
perfectly and why is it called project
2025 they got a name that's when they
want to take over
right um is
there Mar is there a hegelian dialectic
taking place in the United States to
swing popular sentiment in a particular
direction
very much isn't that interesting well if
you take the speaker that was just Ed
ousted the Democrats it's almost as if
the Democrats and and Republicans came
together to get rid of him correct and
what will what will be the result isn't
it going to be a more conservative one
that's going to take his place would the
Democrats really want to vote for
something like that or would they rather
keep a more liberal one normally they
would rather keep a normal nothing makes
sense this isan dialectic that's well
even the inim speaker now removed Nancy
Pelosi and another person out of their
Capital offices yes so there's this this
battle between left and right and the
whole Trump issue and the court cases
and the sentiment that is being produced
it's a beautiful game and I've always
said we are observers we are Watchmen on
the wall of Zion we're not supposed to
be involved and be you know soapbox
orientated we're watching this we're
watching it with great interest
2025 and the papal seven-point agenda 20
277 now one of the issues besides all
the political issues and the moral
issues that they want to address is
Sabbath rest right it says in that
document God or ordained the Sabbath as
a day of rest and until very recently
the Judea Christian tradition sought to
honor that mandate by moral and legal
regulation of work on that day moreover
a Shar day off makes it possible for
families and communities to enjoy time
off together rather than as atomized
individuals and provides a healthier
Cadence of life for everyone UNT
fortunately that communal day of rest
has eroded under the pressures of
consumerism and secularism especially
for lowi income workers does this sound
like the Pope I wanted to say exactly it
sounds like Francis Pope Francis wrote
this it sounds like one of his
songs he should just put it to heavy
metal rock music and the whole world
would swallow this
right and the previous Pope used rock
music to bring across such sentiments I
would suggest it for him perhaps he
would be
successful but Martin this is very
interesting and the interesting is they
want a communal day if everybody would
just do it on one day now for the time
being they realize there are groups that
don't do it on that day like the Jews
that's the Jews and the seventh day
Adventists and the seventh day Baptists
maybe maybe some other little Fringe
groups Congress should encourage
communal Rest by amending the fair labor
standards act to require that workers be
paid time and a half or hours worked on
the Sabbath that day would default to
Sunday so they have a particular day
it's a day in mind and for everything
for the ecology for the environment
for except for employers with sincere
religious observance of a Sabbath at a
different time e Friday Sundown to
Saturday Sundown the obligation would
transfer to that period instead houses
of worship to The Limited extent they
may have F LSA covered employees and
employers legally required to operate
Around the Clock such as hospitals and
First Responders would be exempt as
would workers otherwise exempt from
overtime so in their document they make
allowance for people that want to keep
it on another day mhm and for people
that are working all right now is that a
convenient thing if one says no I want
it this day and another one wants it
that day no it's only going to last for
a while they want a communal day don't
they they say that and then it's with
default to Sunday with default to Sunday
doesn't this also sound like the law
that Constantine brought in the first
time all right it sounds like that law
and the other interesting thing is
Martin if even if they make allowance
for people that don't want to keep this
day once calamities start increasing and
people start playing the blame
game and saying you know why can't we
all be one on this issue after all
Christians wise up we all keep Sunday
let's do it mhm and a stubborn group
says no because that's the mark of the
beast and we don't want to worship the
Beast we want to worship God
could they get fed up with him yes most
defitely could popular demand require
that they come into line or else for
sure so with this interim Rider it gives
us time to preach the message that's and
let's just see it as that and here's an
alternative view while some
conservatives believe that the
government should encourage certain
religious
observances by making it more expensive
for employers and consumers to not
partake in those
observances uh does this sound like
curtailing buying and selling yes you
see so it moves because they want they
said okay people have to pay their
workers if they have to come on Sunday
but now they're moving away from no no
actually this should be no work okay
other conservatives believe that the
government's role is to protect the free
exercise of religion by eliminating
barriers as a OS to erecting them
whereas imposing overtime rules on the
Sabbath would lead to higher costs and
limited access to goods and services and
reduce work available on the Sabbath
while also incentivizing some people
through higher wages to desire to work
on the Sabbath the proper role of
government in helping to enable
individuals to practice their religion
is to reduce barriers to work options
and to fruitful employer and employee
relations Mar is the alternative you we
should actually stop Sunday work Al
together where it's possible for sure
and will unions be involved in this ah
100% so
Martin
L asking the unit United States to wise
up
now and a document already in place for
a potential conservative government to
do exactly that including the request of
lat to see to see to Sunday legislation
is it all in place it's all in place
this the those two documents L out to
see L out to DM and this one is very
much intermingled you can see the and
then the seven-year plan yeah so Martin
if this happs to come from day one
2025 and there's a seven year plan which
started in
2020 then they want all of this done
within 2 years of the new government
taking over right mhm so from 2025 to
2027 we could be heading for very
interesting times maybe even a Time such
as never was a time of trouble what
about prophetic
times and not in terms of time setting
Martin let's just make that quite clear
in case somebody gets a nervous
breakdown but in terms of the unfolding
of prophetic
predictions so the result ample job
options that do not require work on the
Sabbath so that individuals in roles
that sometimes do require Sabbath work
are empowered to negotiate directly with
their employer to achieve their desired
schedule so the employer
says no more work on a Sunday unless it
is essential as they said for a hospital
but even the Sabbath of the Lord in the
Bible makes allowance for that exactly
the same is the prophetic picture
unfolding I believe that you have to be
blind to see this not happening okay so
Martin how loud must our voices become
we don't have any time to sit on our
lels and be quiet
is this part of the three angelss
messages for
sure this
is and that's why we're doing the Three
Angels messages all right so if this is
part of the Three Angels
messages then we have inject the
position here the requirements of God
and the requirements of the Beast to be
implemented by the second beast and if
you dare to go against it you will not
be able to buy or sell they've already
said this in this document there will be
certain
consequences it has to be a collective
mindset all the world wondered after the
Beast it has to be such that it is
linked to some issues so that it doesn't
only apply to Nations that keep the
Sabbath or the Sunday but everybody in
other words the organization that is to
have the clout to implement on a
universal scale must somehow have the
power to implement that as well at the
dictate perhaps of the United States of
America that's it so Mar and our
listeners we believe that we are living
in the very last moments of Earth's
history and the the final that the final
decision worship God and give glory to
him or worship the Beast and honor him
what everybody has to think about and
make a decision on let's
pray Heavenly
Father what an interesting time in which
we are
living so many ideas floating around so
many opposites clashing against each
other so many hegelian issues floating
around and mindsets being forced in a
particular thinking
pattern but we have a
directive an infallible
directive the word of God which warns
against these
issues please Lord Enlighten Minds so
that people can make decisions which
lead to eternal life and not to Eternal
destruction is my prayer in jesus' name
amen
[Music]